oh goodness giving us all a heart attack
what happened um well actually what
probably happened so the doctor says is
what something that happened to me when
I was a kid I probably got sunburned
when I was seven or eight or something
like that and it's sort of that seeds
the melanoma which many years later
transpires and I had my hair cut really
short because we were going away at
Christmas and I needed it to last for
six weeks and so shorter than you would
normally yes exactly and and Jared my
husband went and what's that which was a
like a mole tiny little mole which was a
little bit I've never seen it but I
gather it was a bit red and a bit black
and a bit yellow so that's what it was
makes them disturbing we didn't really
think any more about it and then it was
my birthday January the 11th and I was
driving so that was Christmas time it
was Christmas carried on no pain yeah
and I get in a bit of an itchy scalp in
the winter anyway so it was slightly
itchy and it was I could feel there was
something it was a bit raised about the
thickness of a 2p coin maybe and so on
my birthday I was driving past the
doctor's surgery import em in there on
the market efficiency and I yeah I
thought well maybe I should just go in
because I've you know I've heard of all
these stories and so I went in and he
said oh well I think that's probably a
wart but I'll send you under the special
two-week guarantee thing I'll send you
off to the specialist so I went to the
dermatologist wonderful woman called
Julie Martin dr. Julie Martin she said I
think that's the melanoma to be honest
is not a wart and my heart sort of sank
at that moment cuz I know that melanomas
are a pretty nasty form of skin cancer
but I was very hopeful because the vast
majority of them are early stages and
she said so that was like five days
after I'd see the GP five days after
seeing her she was cutting it out I was
yeah yeah of course there you go so we
can have a look
so she said so she said so she's I'm
cutting it higher next Monday so she cut
it out I was lying about I was fully
awake for this and then a second while
we're looking and they I was I remember
lie they were playing a little respect
nice bit of arisia right and then mr.
blue sky whilst they were asked all the
nurses were asking me about what was
gonna happen about brexit we had a straw
poll in the room and break so he didn't
win so I feel I have no pain in this I'm
not on any painkillers at the time when
that happened I was thinking well this
is probably gonna be alright but then
she said I said what's it like she said
well it's quite thick you know I know
thick's not good but I thought well and
then she said but I've known thick ones
be fine anyway maybe eight days later
nine days later they went off for
analysis it goes off for analysis she
had me in and I took my husband because
they say this is one of the things I'd
say to anybody and take somebody with
you and guessing test results so what
were you expecting what had you said to
Jared as you were heading to thee well
we would you know I've been telling
everybody because I had a plaster on the
back of my head and it was quite
prominent so everybody in Parliament was
saying gosh what's that Chris it's very
obvious you know when we're going
through the division lobbies and so and
everybody could see it and I was saying
look I'm 95% of melanomas are fine you
catch them in the early stage is
absolutely finest on and it might not be
a melanoma anyway so I'd guess I'd kind
of persuaded myself that and the weird
thing was when we arrived in the room
sorry just to say it's really important
to take somebody because you can't hear
yourself what they say yeah because of
the shock that you yes exactly
even if it's good news you sometimes you
can't hear it I've heard tales of
patients not come back for a second for
their next appointment because they
thought that they heard good news when
they hadn't and she was sitting behind a
desk with a file open and that I thought
this isn't great and now she was very
simple and straightforward she said you
have a stage 3b melanoma so there's four
stages of melanoma I'm not I'm not a
medical expert but and I knew that three
was not good
and I you know I just said hey it feels
like no it's fine it's fine fine can we
have that tea please
it feels like being punched in the
stomach and I know I'm nobody special
hundreds and hundreds of people go
through this all the time you know
there'll be people having this exactly
today and the only reason I want to talk
about it really is well in a sense and I
have no choice because it's so obvious
people point at me on the train and I'll
be appearing in the next production of
Frankenstein at the National without any
makeup that but um you know you do want
to cry and I felt cold in my skin for 48
hours and you know I slept terribly that
night and I imagined everything I was
gonna be dead by the end of the week I
was not gonna make it to Easter every
single tin twinge in my body was another
form of cancer and they were gonna
discover when I went forward for the
next thing that you know I I was riddled
with it and all the rest of it so you go
through all of that and having a good
imagination is probably a bad thing in
that kind of moment that some bits of
advice that were really really good
don't use dr. Google because nearly all
of the stuff that's out there is from a
different country different advice out
of date all the statistics are wrong
nowadays and all you do is you fret
yourself to you know into misery second
thing really good thing was somebody
said to me on the first day tonight is
gonna be your worst night you will it'll
all crowd in and you don't have to be
strong it's absolutely fine not to be
strong and sometimes people say you know
look on the positive side and all that
guy stuff it's fine you don't have to
you really don't have to and the other
thing that somebody said which was
really a really close friend and who
read at our wedding
instantly
and and she said you don't have to make
any decisions about anything and you
shouldn't for the next forty into a
Tad's including who you're gonna tell
them what you're gonna tell them because
I'm I told all my mates in Parliament
because I was so blase it was all going
to be fine I told them yeah we're
getting the results of 12 so of course
they're by the time it's 2 o'clock
they're all wondering why on earth is he
not being in touch and I'm worrying
about them worrying about what they're
thinking and actually of course you know
we Jared and I just needed to look after
ourselves and that's fine and so we so
we got through all of that and and then
they do it so the standard thing is they
took out something that sighs the first
time around and then I went to see the
maxillofacial person the maxfactor
person who is who was a mr. Ashworth and
he was amazing as was dr. Martin he was
amazing because he said right Chris
you've probably been worrying about
every single part of your body shall I
just check it all for you and of course
everything was fine
there's you know I haven't got cancer of
the ankle or whatever I'd invented in my
head and just that was an enormous
relief and he was just so rational and
sane and sensible that was lovely
and he said we'll take a larger chunk
out and so since then I've now had they
do a an ultrasound on or on all your
lymph nodes around your neck and stuff
because that would be where it'd be most
likely to go to first and they do a scan
of your CT scan of your body both of
those were all clear and a chunk that
they took out to do that they only took
out that much so that the bit that looks
like a little bit of pork scratching is
from my side they take a bit from here
and they and you may have seen an
earlier picture so that the bit that's
on the screen yeah that it that sort of
heart bit or the bit on the left yeah
that's there's the graft
and and that probably won't have hair on
it but the rest of it the rest of it
will lend I mean you can see already
that it's healing amazingly quickly it's
a bit bloody but so I mean at the moment
all the prognosis is really good though
so the bit they cut out that was clear
too so nothing else in it so you
messaged me and you said oh I've got a
two centimeter melanoma it'll all be
fine and then I never heard from you
again until about three or four days ago
I know and I think it's difficult for
mates and despite our occasional C twos
you are made a very lovely mate but it's
you don't sort of want to bother
everybody with your with medical updates
all the time and friends aren't sure I
think whether to ask or not of course
and for obvious reasons and but I have
to say it so probably people think that
politics at the moment is horrible I've
been in nearly every day instantly
because this stuff I care about and I'm
so angry about this money that they're
giving to all the English constituencies
to try and bribe people for brexit next
week and all the respect and not a penny
for my constituency and I said so in
Parliament and this week and I've spoken
most days and because I don't feel ill
at all but I think I lost the thread of
what I was saying them well that's
perfectly fine you want to treat you to
you I wish I was able to and I would say
I suppose my next question would be
impact on family and how Jared coped and
Howie I'm guessing had to be massively
strong for both of you
yes well he's a star one of the
interesting things when we were sitting
in the Prince Charles hospital in mirtha
turd ville waiting for the second bout
of surgery and it was uncertain whether
I was gonna be under local anaesthetic
for this would you believe Wow
well general I hope you went for general
it's not up to me but they decided the
original
was gonna be local and then they decided
for general one of the things that
really struck me was that 15 years
because Jared came and was sitting there
in the kind of room waiting 15 years ago
there were no civil partnerships there
were no same-sex marriages and I would
have worried about having my partner
there with me because I'd have had to
explain who he was and no one today bats
an eyelid it's not I know but you know
we say of course not but only 10 15
years ago nobody would have thought of
course not people would have been
absolutely scandalized if there have
been two men sitting there holding hands
in a hospital ward mmm so hurrah today's
world is better than the world before I
remember explained to my son just the
other day that in the 1960s I think you
know during my lifetime it was illegal
yeah for two men to have a relationship
together yes completely until 1967 yeah
so and he's been wonderful and being
strong as a difficult thing because if
everybody's trying to be strong then
it's difficult to be weak and you do
have to have moments when you're just
weak together and so I'm I'm very
fortunate in him and in my brother and
all the other members of my family as
well they've been great I love tears now
tell me about brexit can I just think we
were in the supermarket and the security
man came up to me this is head um
because you didn't said cause he didn't
know I was he said I'm really sorry I
mean the the youth violence today on the
star it was a doctor and he said doctors
and the other thing I'm really really
conscious of is that the NHS in Wales
sometimes gets a bit of a bad rap
sometimes it gets mentioned a lot even
Prime Minister's Questions and I tell
you now that if the Prime Minister ever
says a nasty word about the National
Health Service in Wales again I will
projectile vomit at her across the
chamber that said she doesn't then yes
because of odd colic but incidentally I
know people think that politics at the
moment is really nasty and there's lots
of horrible stuff out there and you know
MPs with and panic alarms in the houses
and all the rest
but Tory MPs Lib Dem em please
nationalists have been absolutely
gorgeous with me you know even the
government Chief Whip has been sending
me notes checking that I'm okay it's
nothing to do with him worrying whether
I can be there for the vote it's genuine
you know really genuine and I've heard
so many so many stories and you know
deeply personal stories from other MPs
who either had skin cancers themselves
removed or lost family members to a
melanoma or other forms of cancer and so
on so it's just been it's not a Viper's
nest it is actually full of really
really good people and I know there are
people who in different parties who hate
people in other political parties I
think that was just so stupid